[Music]
yay
i'm streaming hi guys how's it going
welcome welcome welcome good morning one
and all thank you so much for joining me
on this fine
morning to test out the super chat for
good
feature and if you don't know the super
chat for good feature it's basically a
donation tool that uses super chat so
that it can go through
straight 100 of all the donations go
straight towards the charity and you can
pick
any charity that directly integrates
into the system
now this is something that i've been
working towards for a while now
uh some people were uh talking about it
obviously this morning and i was
commenting on the last
stream that wasn't supposed to be posted
publicly that was supposed to remain
unlisted which is usually the setting
but then settings on the live stream
settings usually get
jumbled around a lot and i don't know
why but
as people were saying i was
experimenting with all these different
um
let me turn down this music god this
music is just thumping right now
uh i was experimenting with like the
notification settings because i wanted
there to be
a better way that people could notify uh
me
and interact with me on stream and also
test out these systems so that they
would be ready
so that i could do something like this
which is called scare me for charity
i've got notifications and i've upped it
i've steadily upped it as they go by the
first uh stream i had them like low
so there was nothing but spam the whole
time this time i've got it a more
reasonable
or last time i had a little more
reasonable but it was still a lot now
the alert can only go off if a donation
of 50
or more is there and if even that is a
bit
too much then i'll have to raise it a
little bit more
uh so that only the 100 donations
actually go on screen but i've also got
the event list
so that anybody that donates will be
shown up there and all money goes to the
cystic
fibrosis research institute i believe
that it is
uh there's a lot of cystic fibrosis
charities out there but this one is cfri
you can check it out it should pop up
right in um
right in the chat there so you should be
able to see it as soon as it comes up
and then hopefully
that'll all work out so any and all
donations going
towards me quote unquote me through
super chat
go directly to the charity so this is an
impromptu charity live stream that
you're all joining right now
hope you cleared up your schedule
because it's going to be fun i'm not
going to be streaming all day
but i'm going to be streaming for a
little bit so that i
can give this a good solid test there
kevin beam
i'm broke here's two dollars kevin beam
bing bong bing bong
[Applause]
kevin whoa kevin yeah kevin beam okay
there we go
so now we got that and hopefully my
donation tally is actually going to work
max
there we go hell yeah max you the man
you demand oh thank you and thank you
everybody that's become a member
thank you jules and remember see you can
even see you can even see
you can even see uh it says 100 of this
goes to cfri 100 of it goes to cfri so
this is the super chat for good feature
and i was hoping that this is going to
work out really well oh no
if you weren't here last night i i
didn't even know this was working yet
um but yeah that's that's the thing
if there's a high enough donation my
life
tiger king yo let's do some good
everyone let's do some good
hell yeah thank you guys so much okay so
that's working this is now a charity
live stream
500 [ __ ] dollars everybody give it up
for demented love
at dementedlove just everybody at
demented love type at
demented love anybody that gives a huge
donation like that
give a round of applause it all goes to
cfri
at dementedlove type in type in chat oh
god
marpec thank you so much you can type uh
it should autofill
maybe is it not okay whatever i don't
know where their name is but
had demented love somebody typed
there we go anyway thank you so much for
everybody that's donating now
you can do that anytime and you may have
noticed that there's sound effects that
trigger
when those happen so that's why it's
called scare me for charity
you guys i'm gonna play this uh amnesia
custom story
thank you elisa woods whoop whoop whoop
whoop indeed
thank you so much and also there's a
running list of everybody
who donates on the bottom right i don't
know how well it's going to
update but it's going to do its best
it's it's going to really try
and if it does good then it does good
oh no i meant to that's the one
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
hi ryan hey mark good morning good
morning welcome to the charity stream
uh it's pretty good yeah if you don't
know what cystic fibrosis is
uh thank you the game guru love
everything you do and all the good you
helped to accomplish
it's a it's a disease that was at one
time
uh lethal it was whoa loco alexa hey
mark just finished watching that you're
welcome to our documentary and wondering
when the las vegas show was coming out
if it was coming out to buy no it's not
coming out to buy that is
the documentary that is what it is so if
you go to
i believe their website is cfri.org
thank you john gigi i remember you from
last night john gg
i know how to pronounce your name john
gg you're not gonna fool me this time
john gg
you're not gonna fool me at all this
time john gg
holy [ __ ] tabatha stringham this is the
first time i've donated for videos might
as well go all out well hell yeah
everybody give it up for tabitha
this all goes to cf all right so if you
go to cfri.org i'll put a link in the
description it should update
uh as soon as i oh
boy 200. from emery
everybody give it up for emery thomasini
thank you so much everybody give it up
for all the wonderful people that are
donating so far
um we've just started here let me see if
my little
nope my little tally thing has an
error just a big old error
oh oh there we go it's it's uh it's at
about 2 000
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] juto
thanks for all the joy and awesome
content my guy awesome cause to give to
well thank you so much let me let me
quote their uh their mission statement
so
cystic fibrosis uh it started in 1975.
thank you ramona labat sup senorita
are you trying to propose to someone i
was doing a stream last night testing
out this stuff and someone pro
oh [ __ ] that's so scary oh [ __ ] bailey
west boo
you've been scared by the one and only
bailey west
uh cfri was incorporated in 1975 by a
small group of cf family members whose
children were not expected to survive
their teen years
thank you for your crawler it does help
uh these founding members were committed
to keeping overhead low so as to raise
funds for research originally the
founding members were all gone
emery thomasini again 200
everybody give it up for emery thomasini
thank you so much
any time there's a big donation it
doesn't even matter if i notice it or
don't notice it or anybody that donates
keep the chat rolling is a big rolling
thank you to everybody that's donating
thank you squidward girl how to scare
mark boo
everybody please keep the thank you
train going there's going to be a lot
thank you today
uh these founding members were committed
to keeping overhead low uh the founding
members were all volunteering the first
executive director was hired in early
1880s initially focused on research cfri
responded
100 from scarlet raven let's do some
good let's do some good all right
my lights are going to break from you
guys grew in a million dollar agency in
2012 and continues its efforts to fund
research and to provide education
advocacy and
psychological psychosocial programs and
services to those with cf
thank you elaine mitchell everybody give
it up for elaine mitchell
as well as their families and caregivers
nearly all of cfri's originally founders
have since
lost their children to cystic fibrosis
yet they've remained active and i think
i've got my pause button working
uh right now finally um yet they've
remained active with the organization
because of their commitment to finding a
cure for this debilitating disease it is
a rough one uh cystic fibrosis used to
be a death sentence for children it's
it's
uh as far as i have a rough
understanding of it this is not
something that i fully understand but
this is something that i was talking
with
uh my moderators earlier this morning i
was like what's a good what's a good
cause they were like cystic fibrosis i
was like i
i know if it's cystic fibrosis but i
i've never raised money for it
um as far as i know it's it's what it
breaks down to is
the mucus gets caught in the uh
basically the lining of the lungs and it
makes it harder and harder to breathe
um and this gets worse and worse uh
throughout a child's life and it gets
worse and worse and then
you know it it does it does kill a lot
of
kids and it's killed a lot of kids in
the past but lately
there's been a lot of uh new research in
it new car
uh new uh new new not cures but new
treatments
that have come out of the research that
people have done so if you guys can give
some it's
almost to the point where cystic
fibrosis can be a completely curable
disease the lifetime
i was reading up on it just before we
did this but the lifetime expectancy now
uh where it was barely through your teen
years now it's up to 30 years of life
expectancy
and beyond because if that 30 years
started today
then in 30 years we can hopefully cure
this disease and
keep it going so with that being said
you can find out more in the description
below i'm gonna get started on the game
and let's get spooked abby m
i scared you once before have a nice day
okay here we go
start a new game oh all right well here
we go
ah lindsey grino get lit fam
i am lit i am currently lit i'm as lit
as i can be
amazing and i gotta crank up the volume
again
there we go get the spooks ready to go
oh hi is that a mannequin all right
and sound holy [ __ ]
thank you tabitha this is the first time
you've noticed me and i'm so happy you
said my name oh well
thank you so much and thank you for
contributing to the research
oh thank you england
oh do i have a lantern no need to find a
lantern
ooh crystal oh i regret touching the
crystal
okay just gonna scream it
thank you coffee nut and again
the notifications it's a work in
progress i'm finding the right balance
for it but with
charity i want any and all so it's
charity
bear with it even if you you have any
thoughts towards it bear with it and
i'll
work from it from here but i want as
much possible going to the charity
i don't make any of this money and we're
gonna keep rolling with this okay so i
need to obtain the shard of the orb
hidden beneath the castle
all right okay fine
hannah johnson let's do this let's do it
hey yay i've got the volume like cranked
up like crazy in my headphones too
so everything that i hear is just an
explosion
waylon cook love your recent streams of
what you're doing right now i hope this
helps it does help it really does help
any amount helps
like all the people that are rolling
through the bottom right down there
thank you so much for helping out
and just thank you to everybody that's
been here you guys are awesome
abby am hey mark at my work so can't be
here along
thank you thank you this door won't open
for me
okay i gotta stop standing in the
darkness i
seem to be going a little bit crazy here
okay
mementos the teleportation injured me
badly i need to heal
what teleportation why is that what was
i teleportated
oh poros have fun mark thank you
thank you yeah i could have i could have
called this stream poopy
spoopy sunday poopy sunday as well for
how my family
are gonna be after this pandax butterfly
thank you for doing charity streams like
this where we can donate
hey no problem thank you guys for
donating so much
all right so this uh
mess 3883 payday was friday so i can
finally afford [ __ ]
like donating to a good cause well thank
you so much for that
lana bony my god you guys are amazing
okay
i know that it's it's the opening of the
stream and there's going to be a lot of
these
thank you so much for that and thank you
everybody that's donating so much
holy [ __ ] every one of those is a 50
donation to charity you should have had
charity stream yesterday with all the
donations little i was testing it out so
that i could get everything ready to go
every single tiger king again here's
another 50. used to run cross-country
and charity races with a friend who has
cystic fibrosis
holy [ __ ] what the hell
you guys are awesome thank you so much
for all that
all right i need to find what i came
after first for some reason i was
teleported in here
and i was just tickled to death that's
because what happens is i raise the
threshold on the
on on the final alerts every time i've
raised it every time i've done a stream
every single time and then every single
time it's just like
boom bang oh my god thank you shady
marjah i'm more than happy to help out
and thank you mark for being amazing
well thank you guys for being amazing
thank you so much it'll cool down as the
stream goes on i i've read that this
game
has like uh about
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] thank you demanded love
for the amazing work you're doing right
now
i i've read that this this game has ah
nicole happy to help on this spoopy
sunday also try not to drop your ladder
this time
look look i know i am trying real hard
oh jesus captain smith thank you so much
for all you do you continue to inspire
me i'm so honored to be a subscriber for
two years now i think
holy [ __ ] thank you for all you do means
the world does thank you
i'm glad you guys are amazing you guys
are absolutely amazing god you
you guys are doing this in force i can't
believe it
oh it's dark oh
um should i be in here
i don't know if i should be in here i'm
not sure if i'm supposed to be in here
i have no idea oh
[Music]
every time those lights start to blink
that means a big donation is incoming
all right i can't ah there it is rebecca
a great way to start the week if you
consider sunday to be the start of the
week then yes
indeed it is a great way to start the
week
all right i gotta i can't see [ __ ]
because it's so blurry
in my eyes ah
jonathan you have a huge heart
markiplier you remind us what it means
to be kind keep up the great works
i'm gonna have a dead heart by the end
of this one
emma carpenter love you mark thank you
for sporting a good cause let's get
spooky
yeah let's let's do that i have no idea
what i'm looking for
where i'm going because i can't see oh
300 watts out for spooking chairs
everybody give it up for a and rn
everybody please give a
round of applause for ay and naren thank
you so much for that
the lights are going again i don't like
that
oh there it is chris bass thank you for
actually caring about the kids mark i've
been watching your videos for years and
this is one of the first charity live
streams i've made it to
well thank you so much because i i
didn't announce it in any way shape or
form so
i'm not sure i'm not sure how many
people are going to be here but thank
you everybody that's attending
tanchi you're an incredible person you
inspire me in ways i can't explain we
need more people like you
oh gosh what have i done i'm not the one
that's contributing all this money to
cfri
and if you wanna fellow dica
what's your opinion on the oboe i prefer
the bassoon
okay uh i have a problem because i have
no tinder boxes i can't
jump oh here we go nope
paul and sullivan 200
my god my goodness gracious
you guys are amazing i i i've been
saying that so much i sound like a
broken record at this point but really
honestly that's incredible for an
impromptu charity live stream where i
made
no announcement that it was happening
blue mercy thank you for doing these
great charity stream
boo hey you guys are here donating in
force i can't believe it
honestly this warms my arm thank you so
much i hope i don't sound in oh here's a
door i didn't
oh it will not budge all right well then
i'm going to plow into the darkness here
and see what happens
oh thank you guys thank you ladies
bonnie lonnie bonnie
loco lexa one more donation for good
luck i got to go
but good luck on the charity stream
you've donated like what is that your
or is that 200 either way amazing
oh god i can't see anything
oh grave rob we're not going to let you
play the game keep up the good work yeah
i know you're not oh the lights are
blinking
oh no i'm just gonna
i'm gonna
you definitely shouldn't be in there
what do you mean i should heal myself
before
progressing i can't do [ __ ]
pie man got go but spend this somewhere
good it's going to cfri
all all super chat every cent every
penny goes to cfri
hey 500
hayden becker a great donation
hayden becker hayden
thank you that random one boop your nose
there you go i have no i can't i gotta
heal myself but i have no idea
i have no idea how i'm so confused i
can't see
[ __ ] i don't know where i'm going i
can't heal myself
i can't open this it won't budge
i don't know what i'm doing can i throw
a rock at it a brick maybe
thank you lanny lonnie bonnie oh there
we go nope
brick
oh my god see this is the problem i keep
miss citrus kiss you and everyone here
donating watching are the best kinds of
people thank you for everything
this is the problem see this is the
problem i keep trying to raise the
threshold so that it's less
spammy and it's just to spare me but i
can't be mad at it because it's for
charity
and you can't be mad either ian
thank you it's your birthday yesterday
well happy birthday
you are mother
[Music]
thank you that's so kind of here
two hundred dollars casually donating
for a cheap spook
i'm just desperately looking for heels
i just want some loud down in them oh
thank you ty your shoe
in the midst of all the nice messages i
want to say heck you heck boy
heck oh here we go have i been in here
i'm desperate laura there london
opie opie ah shove it in me
opie i got some sweet opie
ah open
ah opie monica my best friend's 27 and
living a vibrant
life with cf because of new treatments
my heart is so full hey
hell yeah you've got a friend with cf
and see new treatments coming out all
the time and making it
so much better to live with thank you x
fallen angel thank you everybody that's
donating
thank you everybody that's contributing
you're awesome
thank you atlas visitor i swear it'll
calm down eventually
and i if it gets if it carries on for
the next
30 minutes i will i'll stop
chris benfredo good luck today man
football's on but just dropped in to
donate well thank you go football it up
go football it up with your football
people we'll get
we'll get there eventually everybody
you're all freaking out thanks david
this warms my heart
i have cf and we'll be turning 26 on
wednesday research has come so far and
given so much hope
hell yeah everybody give it up oh my god
thank you so much
oh and congratulations and i hope it
only gets better
thank you leviathan i'm glad you're
doing the charity's room right now can
you please give my girlfriend a shout
out she loves your videos
girlfriend shout that's all i got
i didn't get a name jack's awesomeness
thank you so much
and then there's a running list in the
bottom right of names of everyone who
is also donating and becoming a member
as well
oh demented love
i hope he wanted to convince you to
contribute so here is this
that's so nice demented 500
what are we up to hang on what are we up
to now oh my god 100
neocaliber where's your lantern mark i
don't have one
i haven't got one i've made it two steps
in the game
i'm trying i'm trying so desperately
i'm trying so hard guys that's right
oh god we've almost made ten thousand
dollars we've been streaming for
20 minutes thank you jalen it's
something about the navy
what was that about the navy yeah where
was that
oh god oh my god
oh god thank you riana the power of beer
compels me i'm trying
you made my navy life a little bit
better thank you so much we're
three minutes behind on alerts by the
way
oh my god look at me take my money
charity
take it i'm trying
i'm trying so every time i think it gets
quiet
there goes the spirit inspiration to us
two plus two equals chicken
okay all right we're up to ten thousand
dollars
mark back aren't you supposed to be
paying attention to the king
shut up marpak i
shadow everyone deserves a chance that's
true especially me
so give me a chance i'm just trying to
live
all right we're going in the game thank
you jordan taylor you shall never be
able to play this game
i'm gonna play it i'm playing it
here we go hi where am i ah
it's just kids what is happening
rare cure care cure i also have a rare
disease thanks for bringing these rare
issues to light
well thank you so much and i'm so sorry
about that uh
mercy it's not much but i'm glad i can
help for a good cause
well thank you what the [ __ ] what the
what the [ __ ] wait a minute
lindsay pretend it's more love down or
dumb ah
what the [ __ ]
oh thank you quiet one we took you
raising the threshold as a child
yeah you did you really did yeah you did
you did you did you did
oh my god thank you nama we will never
let you rest i can tell
i could tell that okay so i gotta i got
a lantern now finally
so that's good ooh oh it's the broadcast
lantern from uh machine for pigs
oh it's the directional one oh that's
cool okay hello
oh that's scary i like that
oh flicker to it too will not budge okay
okay i don't like that flicker i don't
like it at all
the music in this game is pretty good i
gotta admit i always like it this is a
full conversion mod called the
five magics 300 dawson
raven blood don't lose your mind with
all the jump scares i want to donate to
a great cause
raven blood raven blood
what what the hell oh god not again i'm
just sitting here with my lamp on like
a goof zipline a hundred dollars we love
you from peyton guillermo ashlynn and me
danny well thank you so much
honestly thank you
okay all right where are we
ah um i got a job so i can actually
donate now love what you're doing well
thank you
love what you're doing you're just
amazing thank you everybody that's
contributing
brian robbins i would love to be able to
work with you on charity event someday
bless you and what you do well you're
working with me right now
if that means what you want it to mean
it means that you're helping me right
now and you're helping a lot
thank you shadow marjah love all your
beautiful faces how many
how many faces do i have how many faces
could one man possibly have
egos am i right okay thank you dara
my husband and i love your work you've
gotten us through a lot and m to basic
training thank you for the donation
opportunity thank you for donating what
am i doing
i'm just being stupid smiling panda bird
boo spoops for charity
that's so nice guys whoa this is
the opposite of nice all right
so someone exploded here
um so uh
oh sarah i hope this can help someone
who deserves it
i think it's new i think it definitely
do
okay is there like oil hidden in here no
all right
so what is the whoa
floppy dog donating for a good cause and
a small spook
yeah just a small one okay is there any
reason to jump up there
i can't do it anyway thank you audrey
i'm supposed to be saving up for attack
ah
[ __ ] for a tattoo but i want to donate
more well thank you so much for that
thank you for putting off the tattoo a
little bit for the good of people
with cystic fibrosis thank you la shawna
garrett thank you for everything you do
mark i lost my mom to als
last year and you've helped me more than
you will ever know well i'm so sorry to
hear about your mom
and i'm glad that you could find some
comfort somewhere thank you arnolfo
happy to donate can you say out of my
knees aylin yes
hi alan how are you doing
okay all right
glass jar oh would i need a glass
heather hayden saw the notification
designed to stop by a donut can't save
for the whole stream but i wanted to
help out a good cause
well thank you i don't know how long i'm
streaming this is just again
an experiment see what happens but uh
look over there katrina sheik me and my
best friend lindsey love everything you
do keep up the great work and get spooky
oh we're getting spoopy all right oh
we're getting about as spoopy as we can
spoop
oh we get maximum spoopage up in here
all right okay guys 100
from boondock element happy to scare for
a good cause keep up the good work man
well thank you
is this where i came from no
it's not where did i come from oh
i need to drill bit jasmine yay charity
happy to help in any way i can thanks
for being awesome everyone i love you
mark well thank you
i think that was the only thing in here
cameron you're a bubble blowing baby mr
fischbach but you're an inspiration to
us all and we love you well thank you i
love you guys too
you guys have really stepped up where
you like you could have not stepped up
daniel r a little bit to give to help
someone breathe a little better that is
a great message to it and that's a great
way to put it i mean that that
that's all it is you're just helping
someone live a normal life
pancake jones love what you're doing for
charity please shout out my boys dc and
gavin hey dc and gavin thanks so much
all right it's locked although the lock
is weak so i could probably drill
through that
once i find the last piece thank you all
over blep going to disney is wilford
warstache today
sticking this donation in as my trap as
i travel along the way well thank you so
much and good luck with that take some
pictures
queen at me thank zach duffer congrats
on finding the lantern
thank you thank you for giving us a
chance to support a good cause well
thank you
you guys are the ones actually
supporting it so what am i doing ah
200 tiger king we haven't had a charity
stream in a while we're just making up
for lost time
well i've got plans for a big one next
month
i've got plans that's what i'm building
up towards why are the lights blinking
i am desperately desperately trying to
hold on
but thank you you've donated like 500
already thank you tech canadian spartan
i've been a huge fan of your videos for
almost six years now
you always seem to brighten up
everyone's day no matter what keep doing
what you do well thank you for that
okay so i came from there oh my god saya
oh tanashi thank you okay so i looped
her out
there so there's gotta be like a drill
bit in here this is where this is where
i didn't
i haven't found them i don't think
thank you rebecca manas masamitsu
watch your videos for you bring so much
joy to my life thank you
and i apologize if i can't read
everything i'm juggling a liar we scare
cause we care tr lux
lights are blinking again everything's
queued up so deep that it's like
everything is like delayed by five
minutes in terms of the alert so
we're never gonna get through anything
shelby rainwater i'm freaking so
freaking proud of you thank you for
always being there
for me i love you so much well thank you
so much for being there for the people
that need it most
okay i have not found anything in here
thank you reaper gaming
i'm gonna have to do something about
that
oh my god ah 500
membership hi markiplier enjoy the game
just a little scare my boyfriend and i
love you watching your videos enjoy the
stream
500. amber and your boyfriend
my god abby m mark thanks for everything
you do need to run now bye bye
oh well thank you good gosh
good golly gosh ah [ __ ]
200 i toxic hi mark
hi hi
hi hello how are you doing thank you
do we have a moment of peace
near calvary are you woke yet also
you're one of my role models keep up the
good work good luck with all the spoops
i'm losing my mind i'm losing
it i'm losing it
ah reaper gaming work i love you and
thank you for supporting cfr
thank you thank you
thank you hannah brosu thank you for all
that you do you've helped me fight my
eating disorder by putting a genuine
smile on my face
though i wish i could donate more ah
there yes thank you i didn't catch the
end of that
hundred dollars you're the person i
joined the coast guard wait
you're the reason i joined the coast
guard i'm now part of something great
helping to save lives well thank you on
the gales
why are they blinking again stop
there's too much charity please
i'm begging you i need a break help
let me help me i need help so definitely
i don't know where i am what i've been
doing i'm looking for i've been here
man elaine mitchell earbuds are almost
dead and i don't think my co-workers
would appreciate the screaming i just
i'm trying
so desperately help ah
charity charity losing my mind
okay nice and calm
i don't know where ah [ __ ] laser can i
wanted to give some for charity but i
could watch the stream more but i have
to go
honey good luck though thank you okay
thank you thank you so much
thank you okay
okay all right they're blinking again
aren't they they're blinking
they're blinking they're blinking again
all right i need to find
i need to find the uh last drill bit so
i can drill through that little bit of a
lock but i'm gonna lose
uh thank you that random one it's me
again
you call the members heroes but you're
the real hero no
come on now no ah come on now
cinders watches watch your videos for a
while that's got me through some hard
times i love you well thank you so much
i'm glad my videos can help
in one way or another okay i've got i'm
confused
hundred dollars from ana sadly can't get
my usual 500 super chat but now that i
know about the charity stream next month
better prepare
yeah next month is gonna be the big the
big charity event
gonna have something nice and big going
on for you
it'll be cool oh god what the [ __ ]
i can't keep losing i keep losing my way
why are we blinking again
i'm gonna have to raise the threshold to
a hundred and then
500 or 200 i don't know
god damn it damn it
and thank you don't think i've forgotten
my god obsidian dragon
luigi is that from super mario strikers
i think i recognize that
i i haven't been able to figure out
where the hell i'm going because there's
just been so much spam happening
oh my god that gamer girls terrifying
thought playing welcome to game two
again
never never in your life not even for
charity i was not
demanded love you've already given my
friend sam is that working can i make it
to the stream this is from here
[Music]
yes
stop moonlit melodica you being a hero
and us being ears aren't mutually
exclusive my dude i guess
okay
thank you for pushing us to help these
awesome cause they're gonna be hearing
these movie sounds in your sleep
oh but i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
jump in this well
oh god tory wolf payne you're so amazing
thank you i love you my heart's so happy
you got me through a lot i love you
again
love you too love all of you you guys
are amazing i'm gonna cry
there's plus market mark going state
equals win win i'm not
going insane i'm just a little fluffered
flustered i'm flubbered i
don't know where am i going i gotta find
one last piece of this drill
i just got fired crystal barry this is
what yeah i'm gonna concentrate on the
game i'm gonna shut out all
outside influences all i have is me and
all i am is me
all is me and i and i am one oh
burger man my money can go to a better
place than games little
jokes on you it went to me playing the
game for charity
that's what it was and what it is
oh yeah this is the god damn it emily
knob or cool bean thanks for everything
i just remembered this is what i was
going for
i'm gonna drink my drink
christian mud thank you doing any more
collaboration videos you know what
yes why not [ __ ] it
okay i'm gonna concentrate on
landy bonnie last go then i'll stop okay
thank you lonnie bonnie
lonnie bonnie thank you
lucid blake thank mark for being
yourself we all appreciate it
what are we up to what are we up to what
are we up to
what are we up to that's sixteen
thousand dollars
okay let's all just agree to calm down
let's just agree to calm down might as
well get pretzels derek you know what
derek
no but let's all just agree
take a breather step step back
puka 999 step back for just a spell
we'll get through this together oh get
through this
chanel bush thank you thank you
here's the door i haven't
all right where is this
ah thank you vanessa this is where i
came from so all i gotta do is i gotta
find a way i didn't go in here
ta-da ah and there she blows
all right shannon fake well i like to
imagine these sounds are actually
happening in the game
they are for me okay hang on i'm pausing
pausing alerts we're taking a nice
breather
all right okay the following guide will
cover
all the most important information
regarding the machinery
the main piston which stimulates the
steam pressure in a proper way
needs to be powered with whale oil
though it can also be powered by various
types of fuel well
or only is the most safe and reliable
source of energy
the piston will not move as long as the
furnace isn't lit boiling the water in
the tank below and causing the piston
mechanism to move
once the piston descends down there's
hot enough hot water in the boiler
to blow to generate the required amount
of heat in order to stabilize the steam
pressure in the pipes
which later flows in the mechanisms
above the elevator powering the cog
wheels and generating sufficient amount
of power to raise the gate and make the
elevator able to work
okay go
sir duck thank you i'm gonna try to
concentrate now some sort of inlet for
the
whale oil all right so some kind of coal
thing there
i've got this now there we go thank you
nitro me
i'm chasing my lifelong dream thanks for
doing what you do good luck with that
okay is this cole
cole thank you floppy dog
yeah and thank you to everybody that
hasn't been donating just 50
for these crazy alerts oh
brian brandon boop
boop indeed do i need more
oh god it's happening again it's
happening again
oh zelda lover thank you a bit of good
in this sucky world hey you know the
world ain't so bad
the world's bad sometimes but so long as
people are trying to push the world in
the right direction it can be some kind
of good
canadian spartan you are honestly my
number one favorite youtuber of all
times keep screaming like a baby and
keep making us laugh
i'll try my best no promises on that one
but i'll try my best
all right so let's get oh my god
three ah hey and naren it's me again
getting married in a couple weeks we've
been watching you together since october
well pay for your wedding go
pay for your wedding why you give me
money why you give me eagles boobs for
charity exactly
but known okay if you're just joining
me and you have no idea what's going on
this is a charity stream
and all of the super chat uh
contributions go directly to the cystic
fibrosis research institute the cfri
if you don't know what cystic fibrosis
is you can learn more about it
in the description below through their
website cfri.org
or you can uh ask any around and see if
anybody
holy [ __ ] trevor
trying to be a hero like you mark you
are you already are there was nothing in
here
wait there's
but but dude
but but but there's
but there's there's nothing in there
but there's nothing in there
[ __ ] hell steve for once i have money
to donate glad to help glad you could
help
thank you but there was nothing in there
what was the point of that
what was the point of that i guess
there's there's i i have a glass
container and there's like an
oil thing in here maybe that's the whale
oil
are you the way whale oil
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] whale oil annabelle thank you
[ __ ] was that why can't i look away
the [ __ ] was that
thank you jessica what the [ __ ] is
happening
i heard something all the precious whale
oil
no my fortune
thank you light chaotic all right i've
got the whale oil so i gotta light the
whale oil somehow
i don't know how but i gotta light it
i think i remember the way back i'm
about to can i use the whale oil on my
lantern that'd be nice
no no no no which way hey why wait a
minute
carabao wait which way wait i don't know
which way everybody shut up i gotta hear
where you why you made it
okay all right it's fine i don't know
what that was
spooky rose thank you so much my cousin
athena passed away last year from cf and
to see you having the charity stream for
cfri means the world to me and my family
well i'm so sorry to hear about that
i really am hopefully some great strides
can be made in the research very soon
okay the old vault entrance okay that's
stuck
okay so i think i got to take the whale
oil over here i don't know why i cracked
open that little cabinet
but there was nothing in there oh
randy thank you okay
all right is this uh do i dump my whale
oil in here
okay apparently i do
okay oh [ __ ] okay it's fine
all right so there's gotta be
can i throw this switch now
no i bet i gotta put like the the gears
back
the pelagio you're the best mark i'm
glad i could give something
for something this good well i'm glad
you could too thank you so much for
contributing
that is oh hello okay never mind that
that is honestly amazing thank you okay
so what i gotta do
okay i gotta find i gotta find
something i'm gonna i'm gonna make us
i'm gonna make a quick change here guys
just uh
quality quality of life change equality
of life change
squid or girl i'm i'm back been here
since 2012 thank you so much i'm gonna
make a little
a little change a little change
because obviously it's not going any
less nope that's
man
there we go that one that one that one
that one that one okay all right
okay
that's not how that's supposed to be i
just changed you
i just changed you no
hang on or hold on your butts everybody
hold
tight to your tucuses hold tight
there we go
okay okay
all right we're good
we're good okay
much better much
better okay so
we've got our whale oil we put our whale
oil in that's good
so we need to find a way to get the rest
of this up and running there was a note
that we got
that had some of the stuff so we need uh
piston will not move as long as the
furnace isn't lit
boiling the water in the tank below and
causing the mechanism to move once it
descends there's enough hot water in the
boiler
let's see later flow is powering the cog
wheels so i gotta find the cog wheels
i bet i got to bring those i bet i got
to bring those back here
well [ __ ] might go down soon i i guess
oh boy so if the cogwheels
aren't in here
and if i can't use these and that means
the cogwheel has got to be elsewhere
so i got to go find them i think
i may be wrong area son this made the
perfect sunday thank you
so much for doing a charity horror
stream today you're welcome glad i could
help
thank you okay
so i can't go in there unless did i try
this
no so there's got to be some kind of a
cog wheel storage
area somewhere over here
okay i told you i told you guys it would
settle down after a while could take a
while but it settled down so we got it
nice and settled nice and settle down
okay i don't see a cog well in here
and i've wasted a lot of oil elsewhere
in there
i waste a lot of oil but i think we're
good oh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] so
somewhere here there's bound to be
pj raging hey mark wanted to give as
much as i could last time and wanted to
help this charity been
fan for a while want to say two things
super chat um is it available for people
in my region two people
and two should play scp laboratory like
an mmo for sap
i will i've wanted to for a bit thank
you so much yeah and super chat
for good is only available in the us
right now so if you're in the us
you're you only can do super jeff for
good there so it may not be the ideal in
the end
but super chat for good is still is kind
of a cool thing just to test out
okay i don't know where i
am going i don't know where i
[ __ ] i don't know
where a [ __ ] wheel would be
unless i don't need a cog wheel because
i don't think i've seen
a fully functional cog wheel in this
entire area
i think it's been more of just a rant
obsidian we're going to change i have
seen many
cogwheels i've seen so i'm a cogwheel
salesman
here come to my cogwheel-powered car
i'll open my cog trunk and bequeath you
with cogwheels as far as
i can see
okay so there's got to be
okay this would this would tell me like
if there's nothing in this one there's
nothing
period right so the answer would have to
be in that area why did i open this then
i don't know some of these amnesia
custom stories are notoriously just
uh dickish they they mess with you
intensely
i don't know why and some of the puzzles
that they put forward are quite
perturbing indeed
all right
there we go adam tallman thank you so
much i've toned down the
the noise on the 50 one
all right where am i i've lost my way
no i haven't here we go god this place
is so big and just not enough oil for
anything that i've got going on here
oh thank you coral star taylor you help
inspire small two youtubers like me
thank you for so much what you do
thank you i'm gonna die i'm not gonna
die i'm not gonna die why would i die
why would i die i'm having a great time
i'm having a wonderful time oh [ __ ]
maybe there's more coal that needs to go
in here i don't know of any more coal
oh wait here okay let's try oh
thank you cassandra and the lights are
blinking again
why are the lights blinking here we go
oh nicholas muggio
never under estimate the good you
inspire sir well thank you guys so much
for donating
it's you guys that are doing all the
good like honestly and truly you guys
are the ones
that are doing the good whoa there's
enough coal in the burner now
oh bacon bacon sex
i'd use a vpn to donate from germany
keep up the dork well thank you so much
bacon sex
everybody give it up for bacon sex
thank you squid or girl here's a potato
did that scare you no it didn't
okay so that's loud
hopefully that undid the uh
lock over here i think this is yeah
okay all right okay let's go down thank
you john
bennick hi from tripler army medical
center
whoa beth avat had been a hasty one ever
since his life was filled with anger and
misery rooting back to the day he was
born he had always been a wretched
filthy child society wouldn't accept him
and he wouldn't accept this society
that's
that's an attitude to have oh
okay thank you joseph from rj ej and
calais
whoa what is this
the mechanism is ruined then why even
bother
why even bother have an ominously red
glowing
entirety of stuff
if the mechanism is completely ruined
okay no
catherine me sick thank you for this
opportunity mark you're an inspiration
thank you guys thank you for donating
oh whoa
hi eagles what have i got
the path to the leading to the orb
changer protected by some sort of
electrical mechanism find a way to
disable it
okay uh
okay all right why am i here why am i
trying to find this
whatever this is the sanctum okay we're
going to the sanctum i guess
we'll go to sanctum not much was known
about the mysterious ruin they uncovered
other than them that was lying somewhere
in the endless desert
until they were finally able to enter
the structure looked much older than
anything else they've ever expected
tunnels were blurred with an unknown
language consisting of words that seemed
almost gibberish as if someone tried to
scribble random sybils on the wall
okay
hmm and if you're just joining us today
we're doing an impromptu charity stream
for cfri all super chat go directly to
cfri if you can't donate through super
chat
donate directly to cfri
wolfberg very little is known about this
misty castle its history routes back to
the 14th century when it
was originally built by prussian king
for the rothschild family as a reward
for edvin von rothschild's military
services
though it stood well for several
centuries and further genres
of the family continued to live in the
fortress at some point in the history
something caused them to flee
it is said that bad pandera richtor
love the streams i love you mark happy
to help where i can thank you so much
uh it is said that beth bethavat von
ross child the family's black sheep who
developed a noxious interest in her
heretic magical doings caused his family
mates to flee
because of something he had hidden
underneath something that drove them
nearly insane
what he could have possibly stored down
below in the deep unknown castle tunnels
remains a mystery
it's certain though that it wasn't
something regular although most of these
tellings are legend that grew over
wolfberg
over the centuries passing 50
from neocaliber thank you so much uh
this is the last time i can donate good
luck well thank you so much
all right
i hear a clunking and a clankin
a clunk and a clank clunkity clank clank
clunk
hello oh hello
bones of shadow glad to donate say i do
anubis for me thanks for all that you do
well thank you
i am happy to help out where i can
oh sorry i had to adjust my volume a bit
okay should i shove myself in these
should i shove something in these no
okay
machinery is powered by the electrical
barrier seems to be protected
well something powerful is required to
ruin it okay
so what would be required to ruin that i
could smile at it
that typically breaks every mirror i've
ever seen
oh my god wait
wait wait a minute
hi kayla be spoop have spooky time i
will
i don't like that i don't like that at
all
okay all right what have we got here
oh hello talon
i can't read that
brutally what buy all your cogs at
cogsworld's cogs
vernon you traitor you cheated us you
tried to take the elixir for yourself
and almost got us killed whilst escaping
you dare to vilify my actions sinister
you who are you to judge you are as much
guilty for the death of mathias as i am
and yet you claim that i baxter here
backstabbed him
hi marissa please
you now have my charity donation
virginity love you man you are fantastic
and are the best person i know well
thank you so much
both he knew about the dangers that
awaits him but you
you stole the assets i've been looking
for my whole life
i won't forget this we'll see again
earlier or later
but i'm sure that we will and you
will return the favor okay thank you
i don't know what you're upset about i
didn't do that but
why would you write an angry letter
about it why wouldn't you go confront
him
about that anyway i got a key
i don't know what to do with the key but
i got a key
this is a big loop okay it's a bigger
loop okay so maybe it unlocks this door
that i came across over here
because there was one that was locked
and there was one that there was a noise
behind i mean we got this constant drone
of the machinery here going on there
ah mark has anything been scarier than
paying for college or taxes
will you be making a let's play series
for do maternal yes i will yes
i will
thank you auntie miss what was that
[Music]
lithium bronide sanity potion yeah okay
it's pure lsd can i get something out of
this
no no all right fine then
well either way i got lithium bromide
was it the only thing in here
why did i need to go in here then
uh maybe this
do i need this that's the first cog
wheel i've seen
brick oh oh i almost missed that
mercury nitrate i don't know what that
is or what that would be for
but i'll take this i probably don't need
this but just in case
just in case maybe
yeah i don't know see i told you guys it
would calm down
it would calm down well let me see if i
can shove this in here
shove shove
okay no how about
mercury bromide no then what do i gotta
do
thank you that nerd greece negotiated a
raise with my boss last week and thought
giving to charity was a great way to
celebrate well congratulations
congratulations on that okay so i need
something powerful so maybe i gotta
maybe that's what i could do i gotta
make like a bomb out of this stuff
that's the only thing i can imagine if
only i get away the constant drone of it
all
no oh my god it's just like
agony ah two hundred dollars
knight to dragon junior thank you for
always doing charity live streams i've
spent a lot of time volunteering and
donate when i can keep up this boost
well thank you so much everybody give it
up
but give it up okay i'm gonna go on the
other side because i bet there's
something else over there that could
probably find
so both vernon or bethavat thank you pj
raging
didn't know much about their friend and
come they always assumed him as the most
wise and reasonable one both of them
found his unexpected demise
ironic the most careful one out of the
risky group was the first one to die
oh [ __ ] mr legitim friends thank you for
everything you do and also had to use
vpn to donate from germany
yeah if you're international you might
have to use a vpn but there is
like right now super chat for good only
works in the us
i think super chat works
200 dollars from bacon sex if my vpn had
a face i would punch it
hey about how about some welcome to the
game too no
i'm not gonna play welcome to the game
two ever
ever again never never
ever ever never good god nicolian
complex too spoofish five you marky boo
thank you for all the jump scares thank
you
thank you so much you guys are rocking
it today we are up to
just in this short little impromptu live
stream we have raised
21 000
we've raised 21 000
already for charity
21 000 holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
21 000
what the [ __ ] we've been streaming for
what like an hour
a half what the [ __ ]
oh sorry i'm shocked at that that's
amazing you guys are awesome i
i told nobody about this you guys just
jumped at the opportunity that's what's
amazing about like you guys
and and that's what like i really
appreciate it and and
yes like this it's a ridiculous concept
what i'm doing right here with the
the jump scares for charity and oh god
we're in here now
but it's just like you guys are awesome
you guys are absolutely awesome
i really appreciate you guys sticking it
out for charity and doing what you can
and then like at the earliest
opportunity at no prompting you guys
leap at the opportunity to help out
people that need it
like that's that's an amazing thing that
should not be discounted in any way
and and it's not just like the big
donations going through the majority of
that probably
is all the smaller donations the lower
donations the ten the five the two the
one
like all the smaller donations those add
up incredibly
to mean a world of good to the people
that need it most so just thank you to
everybody
thank each other and just i really
honestly truly appreciate it because
in very few circumstances would you find
that kind of good will just spilling out
into the world thank you chengwei
you would you would very very rarely
find that kind of goodwill just like
willing to be spread like that so thank
you guys honestly from the bottom of my
heart thank you
okay i don't know what i'm supposed to
get by the way
oh thank you to uh pj raging visiting
pax australia unfortunately no but we
are touring in australia in our last
tour i don't know how many tickets are
left
but there are some tickets left
for that event 50
from super chocolate milkshake donating
for a good cause you're such an
inspiration and for month of scares yeah
pretty much
this is the month of spoops
i don't know i don't know what it wants
from me and i don't know where to go
something it just says something
powerful to destroy it
maybe if i mix
no
i'm at a loss guys i'm at a complete
loss
i've got nothing in my notes oh my god
miss caliban your old amnesia videos
gave me a lot of laughs and some really
tough times hope this donation helps
someone else through their tough times
thanks a million and spoop on
thank you something
powerful is something powerful is
required to destroy what does that mean
to be destroyed by my girth i don't know
what the hell is going on
where am i going what am i doing and why
am i doing it
oh something about like some amnesia
cousins swords are
really really really lacking in
instructions
like they're lacking in instructions
lacking in directions this one
is highly rated that's the thing like
this particular custom story is very
highly rated
i found the thing in the bucket oh [ __ ]
my lights i found the thing in the
bucket
so that was important i'm guessing
this is not important because this don't
what the hell
what the
what whoa classy sombra keep the
fighting good fight mark you're one of
my favorite youtubers more so because
you do things like this quick question
would you play more games with jack bob
wade uh yes
of course been busy though why is that
the top's just spinning on that no idea
why
nothing a whole lot of nothing whole lot
of big
bubbly nothing what am i supposed to do
then
there's no direction here there's no
explanation
this is this [ __ ] staring at me
ah something powerful this is my least
favorite thing about these games
is getting lost yes 100 of the donations
from super chat go directly to the cfri
are my lights blinking yes they are
yeah smaller donations don't set off
alerts because if they did it would be
constant spam like it was at the
beginning of this
but they are as always appreciated and
the bulk of it
mr whiteflop seeing so many donate can
inspire love you mark
that's that's that is 100 true you
really
really honestly truly cannot put a price
on inspiration
and uh it seems like a silly thing but
inspiration is a lot of the driving
force of what
like keeps humanity moving it it's like
inspiration flies in the face of logic a
lot of times and i'm not equating this
to anything like
of of the days of old where inspiration
came at the cost of lives but
bacon sex sadly this is my last donation
hope it will help it does help it does
but when it comes down to like uh
certain um certain sources of
inspiration like
things that don't make sense in a
logical capacity but do make sense when
you
when you realize like what it leads to
in the future and and the ideas that it
gives people because
thank you megan a lot of humanity is
just spreading ideas and like sharing
ideas so
having that ability to share ideas with
people and be able to
like say something to someone else is
important it really is
i don't know what i'm doing by the way i
am at a complete loss oh wait no i
didn't check
there was another one ah there's another
over here
what the hell this is open now
has this been open this whole time
during my latest expedition to egypt
i've acquired the first piece of what i
believe forms a much bigger asset
an ancient orb thank you skyler
the orb itself is a powerful artifact
which grants strength and magical force
increasement
though i own only one piece it was like
they found this orb and they found a
little letter next to it it was like
make your
penis so much bigger through the power
of magic
and they were just like it's magical
force increasement
it's free real estate though i own only
one piece i'm almost certain that there
are more of them in this world
currently i'm trying to draw as much
power as i can thank you joe richards my
wife
has cf and it's great to see everyone
bringing more awareness to this
i'm glad that we can uh thank you to
abby fame hey markiplier you've been my
favorite youtuber and to my big brother
my papa always told me to give people a
need and you always help others like
this i have to keep going and keep
giving i will and you guys will too
i'm trying to draw as much power as i
can while also researching the possible
locations of the other pieces
i can't imagine the amount of potential
it is capable of
i believe i found a way to transfer
human mind and soul into lifeless
statues that's not good
jay likurgis thank you so much
i found a way to using the advanced form
of magic conjuration i've been able to
animate a statue using a foreign soul in
mind
though he was very weak i believe that
with the help of the orb shard he will
become more powerful with the
whole orb deformed together my servants
will be indestructible it seems as if
something keeps trying to stop me from
animating the statues
i hear loud noises above the ceiling or
something on sometimes underneath the
ground
i hear something unknown roar in the
distance what can that be
is my mind playing tricks on me or
something more sinister
while being able to transfer men into
statues i'm not sure whether i'm lacking
something or not
conjuration seems to be an efficient
inefficient source of energy for these
creatures
i must find another way but that's not
good
why would you do that wouldn't they be
more useful as
people wouldn't that be a thing that
would be more useful
like infinitely more useful no
just a big no on that one okay whatever
all right so is there something here
that can help me
whoa acetaldehyde yes
please oh that's
a little odd got the jar ready
uh bloop okay all right
i like me some acetaldehyde mix this
with alcitalta okay
is this like an acid or something a full
of substance that belongs to aldehydes
yes ezra starts it's free real estate
indeed it is
indeed it is okay but i think that was
probably important
probably there we go okay
now we've got some progress okay oh
thank you to kyle michaels thank you for
giving uh thank you mark my girlfriend's
niece has cf so it means a lot to us
that people are showing support so thank
you and everybody's donating thank you
so much
why are my lights blinking i don't know
my fears came true it's impossible that
i'm the only one
paul keep up the good work mark thank
you i will paul
thank you thank you i'm scared for my
life are they related to the orb piece i
found
it seems as if they keep trying to
follow me everywhere i go every time i
do something i couldn't sleep with
several
days 200
you need something more powerful huh
obviously this custom game doesn't know
who's playing it
i didn't shove a chair into it let's see
it seems that if they keep following me
around
everywhere i go every time i do
something i couldn't sleep for several
days at all
i feel uneasy i feel alien presence
among my fortress
i locked the cells and hid the key in my
secret transformation
the perspective of getting all those
prisoners isolated from me makes me
slightly more comfortable
sadly though this doesn't solve my
problem
okay what is your problem demons
invading
is that your problem because it's a big
problem i got to deal with here
well there's got to be something here
right one of these books got to be like
a secret
i didn't get what i needed thank you
angel in a music box
my bestie is josie uh who introduced me
to this channel and she's been through
some things including a near-fatal car
accident while she was pregnant you have
helped her keep the strong
thank you bro well i'm so sorry to hear
about your friend i hope she gets better
soon
and uh this is rough
that's rough all around i'm glad you can
find any sort of comfort from my videos
copper sawed and lost his mind uh
gross is randa drank a fluid
let me see if this um acetaldehyde works
on the uh machinery
can you shut up
nope really
no no
no god damn it
okay
uh-oh my lights are blinking again i
don't know why
i know exactly what okay this is just
bizarre
i've never had a game give me this
little instruction
i've had i've had some custom stories
give me like run me around for the
ringer but this game
this game is really giving me nothing to
work with here
i would really just appreciate some ah
mr legitimate friends hello again wish i
could stay for the whole stream but i
got to do a long training event in the
morning also my last donation keep it
spoopy
move i will thank you
damn it what the [ __ ] do i do
what do i do what am i doing what do you
want from me game
what do you want from me i want to
appreciate you you've got a good
reputation
so give me something to work with don't
just lead me around by my dingus
come on give me something
anybody got any ideas of what i'm
supposed to do you guys got any ideas
you guys and thank you to also everybody
give a round of applause to the
moderators for helping out the
moderators are so nice
with keeping everyone informed providing
helpful links in the description below
you guys are awesome the moderators
deserve all the praise in the world
everybody give a round of applause to
the moderators
big big big round of applause for
moderators
thank you punch it
throw a rock at the machine i've tried
that i've tried that
i've really tried that and i've got
nothing thank you to cymore's
bastion cherub art connor brandon bray
miller sean fortner lucy kramer
samantha guerillino tyrell blossom
philip hilliard thank you all so much
is there really nothing in here that i
can use
i mean i didn't get anything from in
here besides the letter
thank you kenneth f burgin the most
frightening is when your mom is angry
and calls you by your fool
i think we can all agree that is indeed
the most frightening moment in the
entire existence of humanity
if you get called by your full name by
your mother especially my mother
who never even calls me by my right name
anyway if she calls me by my full name i
know i'm [ __ ]
basically 100
absolutely destroyed
none your business i don't know what's
scary the notification no not knowing
how to progress anyways i appreciate
what you're doing for charity well thank
you
i wish i knew too maybe i could like
i don't know melt this door
oh lights are flashing again uh-oh
oh oh oh also
uh um i need to ask again did anybody
know what to do with this because i
definitely do not
thank you michael saw that potato
earlier and have to donate i love potato
i guess any reason oh my god sarah
anderson my 11 year old daughter asked
me to donate and tell you
that she loves you can you say hi to
mckenzie we love you my god what your 11
year old daughter
asked you to donate that is so nice
that is so goddamn nice that is so nice
not much was known about the mysterious
ruin okay so i've been all the way up
there
it must be something down here right
use orb on machine i don't have an orb
yet i'm going to get the orb
it must be some wheaton
let me check out here again let me check
out here again one more time let me
check
one more time let me try it one more
time
let me check out one more time
oh geez carpenter mark would you save
her lost in vivo october 20th
2018 i don't know what that is but i can
only assume
that it's something okay so if this is
where this potion
came out of maybe there's someone
in the way
[Music]
no that's behind the painting
close the door i wouldn't do anything
nope i don't know thank you alphazar
mark the marmous khalgar option is still
on the table send it
send in the ultramarines i don't know
[Laughter]
i don't have a favorite in 40 cages okay
so i've checked all the way up there
there was a key in the juice room
what was the juice room i got a key from
in there
thank you lucy kramer sorry this is the
most i could donate i hope this helped
it does
that's a ton thank you so much for that
and thank you to katie warren lucy
kramer
hey boom pod thank you to catlife fives
are cool right i never get to catch your
streams because i'm either working or
sleeping so glad i could make it to a
charity stream
i must confess my love for you
moderators oh that's so sweet
thank you to mark sherman molten freddie
9 alphazar
moonlit rose lady random box uh
oh i missed that one lady random box
markimoo my name's lindsey i met you on
stage with the second detroit show love
the show thank you for all you do well
thank you for coming to the show
we've got just a few shows left in
australia
just a few okay
i am at a loss
i am truly at a loss
whoa molten freddy 90 god live
i like donation good live
good life good live good luck good live
life good life liv what is this thing
wait why is this a
thing what is what is this
then wait
what is what is this
is that anything did anything
nothing there i'm so lost guys
guys i'm so lost this doesn't help
anything there's nothing in there
this is spinning this was spinning wait
it's not spinning anymore
why is it not spinning
there it goes no it stopped
there it goes
rock rock
rock press b to blow
i don't know guys help
ah molten freddy knight lol good live
stream i mean oh
five hundred dollars
thank you thank
you thank you
put the chemicals in the beakers on the
shelf nah that wouldn't work they they
don't
maybe hey let me shove this in here
shove
shove this show no open her up
no come on shove this in here
put that in there
um
oh
no no no
no hammer put
hammer in put hammer in
the acid talking
point fight so real
five things i have a conventional
five unconventional ways you'd kill a
zombie ah
i i i show him a good time
i i i string him up by his ball sack if
he
and if he didn't have a ball sack i'd
string him up by his uh butt cheeks
um uh uh play him uh sweet caroline
until his
brain explodes uh smash him with a rock
uh yell him until everything he loves
and holds dear is dead
five things five things five things five
things
wait there's a there's a wheel here no
that's nothing
guys this might be the end for me
i don't understand i don't know
there's a secret room in the hub well
i'll leave just because i don't want to
deal with the loudness in here anymore
let me just double check this area
i'm not tari my sister and i love your
videos can you say hi her name is cassia
hi cassia thank you
there's no oil left but i seem to keep
getting little bits of oil
thank you katie okay
yes perfect
perfect thank you happy fame
perfect nope i'm out of here
i'm out of here i'm out here
thank you plant zam 69 69 been the fans
and slender glad you follow you on your
journey
thank you for being here okay
marissa thank you oh my god use the rock
i dragged the big rock to the machine is
that really what i have to do
i have to drag a big rock
really is that what i have to do if
that's
i'll do it oh i'll do it oh i'm gonna do
it oh
i'm gonna do it i'm a hi everybody we're
doing an impromptu charity stream
i'm gonna do this i'm gonna drag a big
rock i'm
patrick let's take a big rock
and push it into the cogs
we're gonna go rock to cog everybody get
your rocks out
everybody get your cogs open we're gonna
go rock to cog
there's a big rock was it in in the cog
room i don't think it was no i was in a
different room
i'm gonna drag a big rock a big
rock i'm gonna drag big rock to cog
here we go here we go this is gonna work
this is this is gonna work guys this is
a big rock i got
oh it's really big guys hang on
big rock here we go
[Music]
oh come on now don't be shy big rock
a big rock get in on
get in you sack of [ __ ]
you peace oh you go you get in there
okay we just got to pick up enough speed
okay well
how could you get over that hum but not
over that are you
are you out of your gourd won't you be
out of your gourd right now
come on oh oh really
oh oh but you're not why are my lights
blinking who the [ __ ] is trying to scare
me
i'm in the middle of something ah
hang on i just gotta oh
there we go okay so what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna rip ah
freddy i'm patrick okay no time
this i'm patrick with this
pick up some speed okay we gotta pick up
some speed
get the [ __ ] get the [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of the way
get out of get out of the way get out of
the way get all the way get out of the
way get out of the way get out of the
way
okay here we go are you in the way very
good i can't move you
get out of the way thank you oh my god i
miss up
hang on thank you to molten freddie
benjamin webber
what does it feel like to have so much
influence over people ben you better
500 molten freddy donated 200 in low
gearing
donated a hundred dollars that's that
was 800
in a span of seconds and i missed all of
it why do you do it
[ __ ] god [ __ ]
see that's that's what i have the
notifications on because that's how easy
it is to miss
ah [ __ ] all right i got this
speed pick
it's in it's in it's in close the door
it didn't work
it didn't work fargos it didn't work
it didn't work i thought it would work
it didn't work
so i was lied to
that's the answer here i was lied to i
was just lied to
someone lied to me i thought
i thought that i could trust you guys i
thought that i could trust you
x bubbles i thought that i could trust
you i thought
i thought that i could trust you and it
turns out nope
nope can't trust okay no no trust
okay someone look up a walk through
someone look up a walk just go just go
look up a walk-through someone
go look up a walk-through find out what
it is
and come back to me and only people that
i trust can do
i'ma look on my discord right now i'm a
look on there and
there better be some answers right about
now what is
what is this what is this they're still
freaking
out that people were thanking them oh
[ __ ] well there goes my lights
people were still free their moderators
are still freaking out that they were
moderators can you go look up
how to beat this and then come back
oh dalton beery are you having fun
riding the struggle
uh yeah yeah i am i'm having a great
time
yeah so anyway you guys i'm big rock in
gear
i [ __ ] wonder
okay what's my note saying what did my
notes say a little this is
protected well something powerful is
required to ruin it
well you know what
you know what someone in chat said you
messed up a long time ago
you know what i i messed up when i
started my youtube channel
that's what i messed up that's that was
the moment that i messed up
by even trying to have any sort of
career or
that's what i messed up that's that's
why i messed up
that's what i tried that's why i messed
up
dash the enderman you're awesome mark
you always made me happy when i'm
stressed stay awesome love you bart
thank you but who's gonna make me happy
when i'm stressed
oh super chat from cad life have you
tried peeing on it no
my pee isn't strong enough
maybe if i go back the only thing i
haven't tried is leaving
so i'm gonna leave this one's called the
five magics
that's what this one's called there's no
turning back then well
[ __ ] they can [ __ ] me
i
i was just gonna uh why is there a light
here was there a light goes a little
secret it's mine
this rock this is a rock this rock
there's a secret
book here
i found it no found
something you you no
no there's something here
there are pipes you have to use
the wolf gang hey thank you
[Music]
have you tried turning the game off and
on again you know what i haven't
but screw you i'm gonna get this
through i've been stuck here for like an
hour but that don't matter
that don't matter no no matter none
because there's got to be an answer i'll
need something powerful to ruin it
i'm powerful i'm real
powerful
the pipes do nothing what about this
what about up here do i get on these
no no no
no no no no
no no no the five mad it's called the
five magic
who the heck lady macguffin bow
thank you thank you a hundred percent of
that donation goes to
the this is cystic fibrosis research
institute
you can find out more cfri.org
doing an experiment tyler parks i'm an
hour behind on the video so hopefully
i'll be
i'll see you read this in an hour fcf
fcf to death
thank you i need a flammable substance
and you place it under the wheel
like
thor sent by your clapping reminds me of
slippy slappy sounds of
blank
try reasoning with it cat life all right
wheel
listen you and i have had our
differences
but listen you are a wheel i
am a man we can find
common ground my ancestor invented you a
long time ago so there must be some way
that i can make you die but amicably
so listen it's is is existing even worth
it
huh is existing even worth it maybe you
could just not
exist and we'd all be happier for it
maybe maybe maybe that
you want to just roll over and die
my mod said laurel i said you need a
flammable substance and you place it
under the wheel
and you can throw something on it to
light it that's weird that's with this
guy
it was red the only thing that's red
in this whole goddamn game is what's
behind
this door that i can't get into
because the mechanism is ruined
ace of huskies the past sounds like
steam pipes or you can break a certain
pipe to stop the seam circuit it might
work
it's not real it's a game the logic in
this game isn't the same as the logic in
real life
i've gotta die go into the cell's room i
can't
it's locked i can't go in the cell's
room
it's locked there's i can't it's locked
i can't open it i can't drill into it
it's locked i'm gonna jump
[Music]
wow
aah
[Music]
okay
there was no save there was no se there
was
no save there was no save
there was no save there was no save
there was no save there was no safe
no no safe safety there is no save
there was no saving no save for me
no save you wavy there was no save
there was no save probably because i
hadn't made it far enough in the game to
even bother
saving probably that's probably what the
game
thought so you know that's fine because
i was so distracted by all of the bangs
and booms and the jump scares from
before
hello and then you know it's fine
it's fine i can get through it in five
minutes because at least i know
where to go
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm real oh i'm a spicy meat
ball then i've got good feelings i got a
good feeling about everything that's
going on
so all i got to do is i gotta work back
from the beginning i gotta work back
i've said the name of the game so many
times this is the five magics it's the
five
googly boogalies and it's just
it's the five of my googly boogly bears
and then i just gonna get back
i'm just gonna get back i you know
that's fine that's fine it's fine
because it's fun you know what it is
fine
that's all this is welcome to the
charity stream
we're raising monies for cystic fibrosis
research institute which is a very
admirable goal
we've raised a total of uh
how much a cat life don't forget to
hydrate marky boo oh
27 000 which is pretty impressive
pretty impressive thank you
thank you thank you
okay it's fine
okay so let me bring up
okay so
what i gotta do is i just gotta
quickly go through this whole thing
again
i know where to go i oh yeah i know
where to go
there's nothing oh yeah i forgot about
you good thing i went here
[Applause]
nicholas mugio have a sympathy scare i
don't
i don't think that's how scares work but
thank you
nonetheless it's fine
because i just need to find the drill
pieces that were
immediately available wasn't there
something in there
why did i go in there what was the point
of all that what was the point of that
that screw you stupid [ __ ]
stupid living statue [ __ ] wait
what's over here first there we go
machinery okay
that's the drill that's that i got a
foot got tinder box
got that let me put the coal in the
thing
i i i don't need it now but let me put
the coal in the thing anyway
oh yeah oh yeah
man it's such a discrepancy from the
last one i played yesterday it was so
well designed
so nicely nicely designed
and this one this game game design is a
little bit of a
missing element in this secret passage
in the library you know i
bet there was i bet there was a secret
passage in the library you know i just
bet there was
i bet bing bong of bingabonga there was
i bet i just you know i
bet there was there would be there
would have been there would be
you know what progress is for chumps
and i ain't no chump
thank you for that i missed that richard
madberry hope this helps keep up the
vids and i've been
and will be subbed for an eternity well
thank you so much
all right we've got this it's all good
we have got this we have got this we
have got this
we have got this
aj dolata foxy did the fight of 87.
i think i remember you saying that
before i think i remember that
but thank you for the reminder the
casual reminder just in case
everybody forgot about that and thank
you to everybody that has donated to the
contributions
so far you guys are awesome big small
donations
i really do appreciate that and i thank
you for everybody sticking with me as i
find a nice balance to the alerts
yes i know it can get annoying at times
especially for me
like i am also being subjected to this
but also there's a fine balance because
what i want
what i want is to be able to communicate
with people that is like really at the
heart of everything i do i want to be
able to talk to people i want to be able
to
have a discussion with people i want
people to feel like i'm not just an
inapproachable like [ __ ] at the top
of a mountain you know i i don't want to
ever come across like that so it is
important for me that people are able to
figure out a way to do it
and um thank you guys for bearing with
me like uh also
number one i really like screaming i do
i'm not gonna stream full-time that's
for sure i'm never gonna be able to do
that because i never have the
time to do that but i am like you know i
do wanna stream as much as i can
you know whenever i can and i think i
think there's something very nice about
being able to communicate with people
live and in person there's something
about that
so it's it's important to me to have the
opportunity to do it
it's important to me to try to like live
up to the expectations that i have for
myself when i do normal videos
in terms of live i don't want to live
stream shittily
you know what i mean i don't want to do
a [ __ ] live stream i want to do the best
in everything that i ever do
whether or not that's like um what was
the point of opening this
oh what that wasn't there before
what the hell yeah anyway like i have a
i have a certain standard for myself
like i like to
make sure that i do things as best as i
possibly can
and that includes like trying to be the
best in terms of live stream
and when you're live streaming like it's
a very recognized fact that you gotta
acknowledge when people are trying to
give you something
or contribute to a cause and i wanna be
sure that i am as best as i can be in
terms of that department so
that is why i do that and that's why
it's important to me and that's why also
these causes are important to me
like the uh the charity causes too i
i've spent a lot of time in the past few
hi i'm coming with you i'm coming with
you i'm coming with you i'm coming with
you
i'm in here with you i'm gonna be
trapped in there aren't i
oh [ __ ] well oh oh no oh no
no oh no oh no
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
oh phoebe 300.
why did it save my game then
why would it save my game then but
that's okay
i guess
[Music]
where is this one
wait a minute
oh here i go
mother flipping
flip flapper flip of a flip flap
mumba flippy flap flumpy flop
flim flap flip oh
all right it's fine this might be the
most rage inducing
amnesia custom story i've ever played in
my entire existence
i might actually i i think i'm gonna
burst blood vessels
while i'm playing this one i'm going to
literally like lose
i'm gonna lose years off my life because
of this game
like this particular custom story
oh oh it's just so fascinating to see
how
people can just make things go wrong you
know they i
see that the developer has the best of
intentions with this game
and yet you know you can see just thank
you dalton do you need some spaghetti
for your upsetting
that's hilarious you're funny
yeah yeah i really would like some
spaghetti actually
and it's fascinating because i've made
it barely like two
probably two percent at five percent
into this game's
intended ending because they said that
this game has
three hours of content and i've made it
through ten minutes of it
[Music]
but it's fine fine
thank you phillip it's fine
thank you thank you steph thank you
it's fine all good
in this neighborhood where the heck
is this
right here
all good all good all good
it's all good it's so
good
i'm going to turn off hints also because
that's i don't know
okay armin mark i love what you do keep
it up you're the best thank you
thank you so much thank you
okay i've got my whale oil i just need
to go get the jar of large oil
and then i am back to where i was
oh baby a triple triple times that i got
stupid but triple times that i'm gonna
win
bam get me got it
hell yeah oh yeah thank you brian
flammable substance under cog then throw
a metal looking box at it love your
videos watch all the time
i don't know what any of that means
i don't know what a goddamn thank you dr
j i don't know what a goddamn thing
you're talking about means
so i am gonna do what i gotta do when i
gotta do it
and then i gotta do it now
where am i going am i going the right
way yes i am hi buddy okay i'm not gonna
make a mistake i made before goodbye
oh taylor you look tense did you forget
your pretzels
i'm i am hungry thank you very much
for your contributions to my
loss of sanity but you know it's fine
whatever
everybody just poke fun
marky moo is being stupid again
thank you heretic yeah
but you know it's okay because i i'm
gracious
and i am good i'm a happy man
bris lee one love when you do the
charity thing oh i love when you take
the picture thing
well thank you so much come home we're
good to go
let's get out of here all right
and just like that baby just like that
we are going to be back
where we was were before thank you
charlotte hughes you got this mark
you're a big brave boy just use your big
old brain
oh i'm gonna oh i use my big boy brain
all big boy day
my big boy brain all big boy day oh big
boy day all big boy brain all big boy
brains all right my big boy brain
wretched filthy child me that's me i'm a
wretched
filthy child i'm disgusting oh
[ __ ] the red light of truth has sounded
all right i'm going comfy mode for this
from now on
we're going comf mode everybody get
ready for a load of comf
i i'm sorry uh that that is not what i
meant to say
no uh phoebe darling thank you so much
for that
i
this is everybody forget i said that
all right anyway
a library so someone said there's a
secret passage of the library and i
would believe that because
i would not believe that this library is
just here
for the sake of being here there's got
to be some kind of a book
that pulls some kind of a
well what what you you oh you just
pulled the whole thing
[Applause]
oh wait come on
come on come on come come on are you
really
are you stopped by that book and you are
stopped by that because you stupid
what are you
what what are you stuck on what
what um
i like cheese i did too but i've been
trying to cut back
it's right here oh
activated
it's not it's stuck the charity is for
the cystic fibrosis research
institute
all right
i don't know anymore i don't know i'm
gonna leave this area and i'm gonna come
back because
the only thing that i can do is
to the only thing that i could possibly
do is go away and come back
and that's it so there you have it
i'm gonna go and i'm gonna come back and
that's all there is to it
and i'm hoping that it's gonna reload
that thing so that i can try again
[Music]
and come back i'm also gonna go get
whatever i need from down here first
so yeah that's good how are you guys
doing good great
i'm such a comfy baby i'm a comfy baby
this is called the five
magics this is the five of magix
i'm currently doing a speed run of it
five magics get this i get this key
and do we got
there we go open that up look in the
bucket look at the bucket
look at the bucket there it is mercury
nitrate got
that anything else lithium
[Music]
hello you can keep scraping all you want
i'm not gonna bother you
then we go over here then we go over
here and we look in this room
and we scream at the wheels
and then we run away and we got
everything we need and hopefully the
library is going to be reset so i can
actually go through it
okay you have ice cream god you're going
to make me hungry
i wish i would i should have food i wish
i had any sort of food
i wish i had some kind of a food
substance inside me right now
[Music]
casey cooper oh no mark you fell into
the 50 to scare side everyone wants to
scare to not everyone has 50
all said in love i don't know what
what did you just try to say i have no
idea
okay i'm gonna turn the 51 back into uh
the actual scare sound
so uh i think it was um
yeah all right i'm gonna turn it back
oh wait no that's not right oh
what no that's not right
wait there we go
that's the one that's the one and i
gotta hang on
hang on thank you so much to jesse e
love you mark for all you do
well thank you
okay
okay all right
okay ah
there we go now that it's calmed down a
bit maybe we can
actually survive for a little bit longer
okay so if we
lily elizabeth lee said i'm gonna die if
he says my name well too late oh no
what the what the [ __ ]
what the what where did what
where did all these books come from what
the hell
oh on the gales that's the first time
it's been synced up
properly those are supposed to go as
soon as that the members discord is
cheering for you well thank you
it's still stuck i don't okay
uh i guess i'll try to climb up and
get over it oh no
oh no oh no
oh no i would cook for you for free said
demented love i appreciate that
i appreciate that i do but that's okay
i'll just get some delivery or something
oh right i can i wedge it out
oh no wait i oh that i think that worked
a little bit
[Music]
chair always works
chair always works chair oh
oh [ __ ] chair didn't work okay
so there's got to be something here that
we can do this
too but we're on the oh we're on the
precipice of progress
we're right on the edge of progress big
rock
i need a box somebody give me a box
i need a box thank you i'm dead inside i
i
i understand that feeling so well
okay barrel yes
thank you garrett shafer mark who's the
friend in there with you i've never seen
them before
thank you sarah dunda happy to donate
i'm still worried
who's in this room with me
oh my god
it's stuck
i don't know why it's stuck but it's
stuck
it's so permanently stuck
it is just absolutely stuck
i don't get it i'm gonna try to like
reload i'm gonna save and exit i'm gonna
go back in
i don't know
[Music]
i've gotta try i don't know
i don't know thank you the mcgah
meg gavin thank you for inspiring me to
bring more good into this world i
appreciate that dude nope
it is just stuck
[Music]
wait it's moving a tiny bit tiny bit of
movement
it's moving back into place
that's weird it is moving wait
i'm wiggling it it's it's moving a bit
and i guess a bit of movement is better
than no movement but it's moving
back into place
okay i
i wish i wish upon a star
i wish upon a star
i wish upon a star thank you butt monkey
thank you butt monkey
thank you mr halex thank you the mega
vanie
thank you king catfish thank you anthony
kankowski
fandom maniacs gone ascension sarah dunn
garrett shaffer slenderman deadlock
gaming laney spangler daresh demented
love on the gales
pull it towards you oh pull it towards
me
a no is that all oh
okay
okay okay
it's close it's only closing it's only
closing
it's only closing
like no matter what direction i pull it
in it's only closing
i never thought that the most harrowing
adventure of this entire game is going
to be moving this
[ __ ] bookshelf use the plank to move
the shelf
i don't have a plank i don't know how to
plank
i don't have a plank there's no plank
there's nothing i go oh my god
did they program this particular custom
story to make things get stuck
extra easy okay
okay pull you and then pull
paul nope okay
guys
guys i broke it and it's closed
and it's closed and i've closed it
and it's closed
[Music]
is this before or after i already opened
it is this before or
after is this before is his afters after
before before or afters before or
after mark you need to get in there
i know i need to get
in there i am very aware
i will not be beaten
by this god damn
bookshelf
i refuse i refuse to be beaten by a
i think this bookshelf is trying to
break no not
here no [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
niley can are you telling me
are you telling me that the autosave
only either puts me
there or
where exactly
we are raising money for charity
we're raising money here we go here we
go we're raising money for the sifting
fibrosis research institute
it's an impromptu charity stream we're
doing a great job
every penny you give through super chat
this money that goes a directly to the
charity
directly directly i don't get any of it
it goes hundo pussento
luster nicholas man charity sure is
spooky you got
that right there's special alerts so you
could scare me
for charity
was that so hard
my god was that
so god damn hard okay
we're in
[Music]
we made it we made it guys we did it
they thought we couldn't do it but god
damn it we did it
they said we weren't good enough but
god damn it we did it so yeah oh
i got the cells key baby i got the cells
key to the cell games
and we are going to now make power grass
you know it baby you know it
baby you know it baby we are going to
make some progress all right
re-engage chill mode activate
we got this you know we got this
we got it thank you for your donations
to the charity
we got this activate chill mode
ah lots of comf oh
maximum comfitude engaged
ah
now that is what i call a nice relaxing
stream
were we playing a horror game cause i've
completely forgotten
you know i just wish that i could
even remotely appreciate the finer
things in life
but alas i cannot this
is five magics
ah
it's an amnesia full story
thank you the okami project
if everything i'm saying sounds
sarcastic to you
you're not listening hard enough
so how are you guys doing
good to hear that's so nice
okay
[Music]
someone's making a ruckus over there
okay
keep your chin up marquee zeta butcher
thank you so much for your donation
thank you uh dragon girl thank you
catherine colbert
it's fine it's totally fine it's so fine
and it is
it is fine thank you erica meaner
nicholas reeves anthony konkowski some
phantom boy dim grim shaylee kaner
ac outdoors luster nicholas
uh asriel dramura scott moon
nanski dim grim melody howard and
magzy r
ah dragon girl said i was told i have
the personality of a house plant
i doubt that very much thank you alan
hensley
into the cells we go it's the cell
games bra brought to you by heat up
all right i'm ready i'm ready
scare me oh daisy rat
tasty rat okay
uh um
why why why why are we doing that why
would we do that we don't need to do
that
ah do i i don't know what's happening
mode disengaged you behind me
why oh oh my god you are um
oh whis oh if you if i die do i die for
i
i don't want to die do if i die forever
no please i've come so far no
why would you do this to me don't do
this to me don't do this to me
please be oh yes no um
uh uh in the closet maybe oh my god go
go go go go go go go go go go go go
i forgot this was a horror game
that was too close
okay ah
maurice doe cleese yeah you're still
alive alive or live yeah
i'm still alive i want pizza
i'm real hungry okay
all right i think we're okay i forgot
this was a horror game
tinderbox superb
tinkerine hey oh papo you've seen better
days
jonathan dallas hey my sister had cystic
fibrosis passed away seven years ago on
this day thank you for supporting this
charity i'm so sorry about that what a
weird coincidence
hey blinker i don't want to scare you
but i want to help out
don't worry you did you you didn't help
i mean thank you i guess
all right okay all right
[Music]
so okay
we're fine i don't know where that dude
went
but i think it's okay
[Music]
you sack of [ __ ] new sack of [ __ ] new
sack of [ __ ] you
think that's gonna scare me a few books
blown in the wind i'm too much of an
expert at this game to even be
remotely spooked by the likes of that so
don't even think that you could get on
my level of spookage because you cannot
after many hours invested in studying
alchemy i've created an
interesting recipe for a substance which
i call mercury fulminate
it's created by mixing aquaphortis with
mercury nitrate
and then heating the secreted substance
on a burner after the chemical is warm
enough the burner shall be turned off
and the last ingredient needs to be
poured in
acetaldehyde the liquid is now ready to
be collected and stored
eric meter you should play slendy
tubbies the devil among us
okay that sounds like a fun game
the liquid is now ready to be collected
and stored for a short period of time in
the safe
is that delayed or is that new i'm
assuming that's delayed though i don't
have any use before yet it might come in
handy if removing the rubble
blocking the ruined tunnels which
pierced the castle from down below
the fortress has a solid structure so
using such brutal substance shouldn't
worry me at all
i'm still in search for the remaining
orb pieces i've managed to determine
that one of them is located in the
ancient four lone underground underneath
the city of center hold
just just 20 kilometers away from the
castle the tunnels shut underneath the
area are
most likely to be built during the
periods of roman empire although due to
the difficult conditions present
here i'm not going to be able to go
there just yet i need more preparations
perhaps i should
send my trusted servant howard
joseph call the blacksmith you know i
don't think the blacksmith can help me
at this juncture
okay so i need to find a burner
that seems to be the long and the short
of what i need to do i've got the
hiccups
but where do i do that okay so
all right whatever so i don't know why
their prisoners still
alive down here or how they're even
alive
and man is it just me or is this music
like blaringly loud
what is with the music in this game and
being obs is is it just me or is the
music
obscenely loud in this game like it's
just like
yes yeah is it is it loud
that's just you maybe it's because i got
the volume like cranked up i don't know
what it is
a little bit loud it is loud it's like
super loud i don't know why
the music is so loud i don't know why
the developer was like
opening puzzles impossible and the music
loud to keep them company the whole time
through
they ain't getting bored in mine my game
not mine all right
so there's got to be there's got to be
something else in here
right i wouldn't have just missed it
where maybe where the
shelf blew off maybe the shelf blew
itself
um i don't see anything in here i don't
see a burner i don't see a secret
passageway thank you agent shepard
i don't see anything
nothing behind the painting nothing
there nothing there okay
so it's got to be in one of these other
things right it's got to be in one of
the others thank you
wind image it just has to be oh maybe he
was upstairs oh no
there was a lot of stuff upstairs
sciency looking stuff
so there's probably something upstairs
some kind of a burner here
no no bernie no burner
no burners none really none okay
whatever
all right let's keep looking in here
then i would imagine that in one of
these there would be something
i just gotta find it right
some of these are open
no no
you're locked because you're either dead
or sleeping i don't know which i'd
prefer at the moment
maybe i could drill my way through here
no
this one's open
i guess i would see something of use
before i
before i just need to go in there no
no
no nope
whoa whoa dude you all right man
you don't look so good you all right oh
he's probably fine
thank you wait oh this is a different
hallway
okay
oh where's this lead
oh this one's open is this by design
no is it just nothing is this a whole
lot of nothing really
okay good great all right
that's wonderful
hey he's probably fine
i don't know where that dude went i've
only got
i've only got two of the ingredients
that i need
i do need one more i've got acetaldehyde
and mercury nitrate
but i need that ferrous whatever that
was thank you alexandra
so there's got to be something in here
that i need
they wouldn't have all of these cells if
there wasn't
something that i could get right
probably not
no i'm back here then well [ __ ] dick
well shitty kid
no oh there oh there it is aquaford is
okay some people were saying that back
in the library where i first found this
stuff there was a burner
so i'm gonna head back there i've got
the aquafortus
i'm gonna do that burner in the red room
you got it baby you got it
you got it i get it okay all right
let up do it sumiya hey mark could you
give my friend ammon a shout out
he's in the navy you want to make her
day hello
let up off me okay my brain only so much
capacity so you gotta go easy on me
oh yeah everybody burn her in the red
room
burn her in the red room i get it okay
i get it i got it you think i don't got
it i get it
listen i get it i got it
you trust me i got it
i get it i get it i know it
okay aquafortus all right
nothing to heat well there's about to be
okay
[ __ ] prank game plays oh wow my message
gets pinned for half an hour i better
say something cool
um okay
okay
[Music]
foreign
ah it's right there
nothing to heat you say well
boy i'd love to give you something to
eat
right there no right there no
right there
that's my bad that was my bad that's
i'm fine i'm fine
i'm fine
got it nailed it
got it i got it i got it guys
i got it guys i got it i got it
i got it i got it i got it me and big
brain big smart me i'm smart big brain
me and big brainy smart man
miam have big smarty brain you guys know
me brain
me brain am big how big brain everybody
in chat
say brain how big me brain how big m
brain
cause me you know me uh oh me brain
am real big me brain super big
me brain m s mega big how big brains big
mouth i have your logo on the side of my
semi trying to help spread your
squirrely love and weirdness across
events
well thank you that's that's so sweet of
you that's so nice
oh but me and big brain me i'm the
biggest brain that ever brain
there it is some of those need to be
struck with a great force in order to
explode
well i know what i need for this
me and need rock me am need big brain
rock for big brain splode
city and dragon change by the way you're
here may i need
small rock me i'm need small
bag of sand for small brain explode me
and big
brain rock oh yeah hey everybody in chat
if you know say brain how big it big you
know no brain big
you you know brain big now me and big
brain
her brain how big oh so big they say on
animal planet brain big of mark big
smart
here we go big brain rock oh
i can't pick up rock at
rock big here we go please do not
blow up with me next to the big brain
rock incoming
amanda rock i'm 34 and have a rare
condition thank you you have helped my
mental health struggles well i'm happy
to help and thank you for donating to
the cfri
okay all right me and big brain work
this out if rock not big enough maybe it
not about bigness maybe about hardness
maybe need harder rock small more
precise
me and big brain know when to use big
brock and me and big brain know when to
use small
rock
[ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] ct donate to charity to achieve
maximum galaxy
that's what i've always wanted i didn't
know it until this very moment i've
wanted
maximum galaxy brain that's what i've
always
truly desired
thank you so much my maximum galaxy
brain
bigness brain bag
okay so that destroyed that mechanism
so it should have destroyed yes
only now only down to a moderate
zappilay
let me make sure i can go through this
okay
so i'm gonna get this orb in the orb
chamber oh i've got this i've got this
now
i'm gonna turn the volume back up so i
can appreciate any spooks they got for
me
okay oh no loud here we go
ah easy
okay orb chamber
we got this oh yeah baby our big brain
working
at big brain maximum capacity it's still
loud
why is the music so goddamn loud in this
game
okay all right
okay oh i see
you i see you you think you can hide
from me no i'm a big brain too big
[Music]
okay all right
oh thank you burf okay
why do they have all these boxes
everywhere that's what i gotta know i
can't even break them
thank you rashford
okay all right i feel you i'm feel
okay i'm feeling you oh
all right i'm feeling you oh i feel you
set the great fire of blaze restore the
great knowledge
please me with sanguinary ritual show me
your big brain
okay being in great danger i've decided
to start moving my abode to the ancient
shrine of uncovered in the kirchlinger
forest brandon wheeler why you now play
space engineers you know i ask myself
the same question every day
the shrine brickton buried under the
rubble by the locals who's claimed it
been haunted ever since
it's so loud it's so loud
the most promising one concerns of
mithraeum
is this really the time to go
the passages have been secured by the
worshippers just days before we were
forced to flee though
it is unknown what caused them to do so
but i have my assumptions
it could have been an orb shard
potentially but as for now it is still
unconfirmed until i will finally settle
down
in one place i don't know what will
happen to wolfberg
i will do my best to blur all the traces
i've left around the castle
it can do it can as well fall apart as
it will not be my personal matter
anymore
the shrine seems more promising not only
is it located
in the middle of a forest where no men
dare to go but it's also hidden
underneath the ground
giving me the perfect hideout from the
outside world no strangers will
interrupt my work why so
[ __ ] loud
maybe i'm just maybe i'm just on edge
but this game
has just given me a little bit of reason
to be upsetty
someone give me some spaghetti
okay
ah what are the donations at
we are at let me one second
we're at 31 000 we have
no goal by the way we have no goal
we've only been streaming for a few
hours and
all i've had is annoyances and terrible
terrible terrible gameplay and you guys
have raised
31 000
that is absolutely amazing
thank you so much for helping out with
this that is astonishing
i i just want to take a second to like
stop and just i know
i've been being goof and i know that
this has been like frustrating for me
and everybody watching but that is a
[ __ ] ton of money
that is a stupid amount of money to just
suddenly rain out of the sky for a cause
that is really really necessary because
right now it's on the cusp of something
greater
and a final cure cystic fibrosis is a
disease that basically just
destroys your lungs but with the
advances that we can make
like we can really do a lot of good and
and this is another thing where
i don't touch any of the money it goes
straight to the cystic fibrosis
research uh institute or incorporated or
whatever it is
like this charity is one of the highest
rated charities in the world
and it is just a great cause so thank
you
like a personal thank you from me to you
guys you guys
are awesome you guys change the world in
every action you do
and to know that i don't even need to
ask you guys
to do anything and you guys do it anyway
at the drop of a hat at a moment's
notice you are
ready willing and just like so poised to
spring and do good will
that is just something that can be an
inspiration for everybody out there
and it's something that i really truly
never want to take for granted so thank
you guys so much
uh for that and just thank you for
everything that you do
and uh also i want to say that i will be
contributing
five thousand dollars myself to cfri
i just can't give a super chat to myself
would that even what that even look wait
maybe i can't i've never tried
never tried let me let me try yeah i'm
gonna try and let me try this
i've never i've never done maybe it can
because it doesn't go to me
okay so the max the max is 500.
okay
yeah let me try this
also it's really cool because the
donation thing is right in the chat
like it's built into that if you don't
know how to give uh super chat i don't
know if i've
even mentioned how to do this there is a
little
heart hand thing down below in chat
right down there
what did it freeze uh oh
oh it falls
it froze i broke it um i don't know
what i just did but that is completely
broken now and i
am i still live
am i lying am i can you guys still see
me am i still oh
oh [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ] oh
oh [ __ ] that's a lot of error
that's a lot of wrong those are numbers
oh god oh no oh oh i broke it
oh god no oh
i am i live can you see me
i don't i can't see any none of my all
of chrome has crashed
i think i'm still live so if you can
still hear me help
help help help i broke it
oh it's so broken oh god it's broken
everything is broken oh god everything
is so broken
i've never seen errors like this before
in my life
oh no i swear i've
never seen this before i have no idea
what's happening
i can't see anything i've got to just
close everything
and reopen it i have no idea what's
happening
okay all right am i still live
help oh demented love you are live
okay so you can hear me i can't click
anything i can do
nothing i am frozen in time i have
oh god oh god
oh chrome is so unhappy with me oh no
okay all right i'm just gonna close
that close
oh jamie boyle every time you get a
super chat i jump which causes my two
goldens to look at me funny
i jumped too okay close that
help help help
help okay i promise
if you do the super chat thing it won't
do that
has that been happening for people have
you guys been trying to give super chat
and it just completely shatters into a
million pieces
so if people been trying to donate more
but it's just been exploding everywhere
because i think you guys uh oh oh no
oh no okay well okay all right
it's i can't close chrome so i gotta
force close chrome real quick hang on
oh my god i wish i could show you what
exactly i'm seeing
it's like every window in the window
that says like the super chat stuff
thank you on the gales help this man he
needs some milk i do need milk please
ever the analytics the video itself all
is its own
box of air messy i have some money's for
the charity could you say hi to a human
named tyrion please
hi tyrin but every box is its own error
and i can't close it anymore
so there's that then
okay i'm just gonna let that
be that ah
do it zumamia i want hero patches for
every shirt i own
i'll get those to you very soon
i can't play with my webcam it's too far
away
and uh i can't move it anyway so it
doesn't work that way
cute morbid fox i don't know how to help
you from
wait i i missed that one i don't know
how to help you from new york mark well
oh well i guess that's as good as you
can get thank you though i don't know
why the lights are flashing but
thank you tiger shoe why don't you
donate from your other account instead
of breaking everything you touch
i look look i don't know i can't log
into my other house
thank you zeven i'm in the army and i'm
in a aut
and you help me so much you make this
worth it and my name's just pronounced
zavon
well thank you so much for that
okay all right what up
hello baby hello how are you doing
what do you got in your hand oh a skull
okay all right ow what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i didn't want to do that
geez
what did i miss uh sorry molten freddy
how do i become a member
there's a join button down below or in
the description you can go to
youtube.com slash marketable
join zz will we get to 50 000 will you
eat chicken feet
no there's no gold on this no
i don't even have chicken feet where
would i get chicken feet
okay whatever all right so i stabbed
myself with that i don't know why
okay i made a sanguinary blah blah
i think that's what i was supposed to do
um
okay back to the game i guess
there was something about the
instructions right it was like give a
sanguinary what
chicken feed is not good did you not
hear my chicken foot story
no no no no no no no chicken feet is
the opposite of good
ugh well it was like one of the worst
things i've
eaten ever restore the great knowledge
please me with
sanguinary ritual oh god i please you
okay
set the great fire ablaze does that mean
these do i need to finish off these
is that what i needed did i do it
ah [ __ ] i probably just wasted my tinder
[ __ ] redfish notice me mark okay i did
thank you all right so there's gotta be
something else right
curls and sass i will fix all your
problems if you marry me
no and that's definitely not a proposal
to someone else that i'm misreading
oh streaming you sean good speed thank
you for everything that you've done to
donate
the donation area is right down below
you can find it directly below
the chat it's actually built into the
chat if you've never given super chat
before
like it's right down there it's
integrated all through google and
whatnot
and uh it's tied into my alerts so you
can scare me
for charity hence the name
super killer have you tried turning it
off and on again here's the money for
charity can you say hi to abby for me hi
abby
how you doing okay so let me check my
notes
okay these are
old these are old
uh thank you to leonard leonard church
zevin frazier eric cruz zeta future
uh zeta what's the weirdest thing you do
if we get five thousand
fifty thousand i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna do anything i'm not gonna do
anything you're not holding me in any
promises here
this was all voluntary i did i'm testing
this is a test
you guys are gonna raise fifty thousand
dollars in a test
this is this is the test
huh okay so anyway
uh i don't know what i'm doing i have no
instructions and i don't know anything
anymore so there's that
ah krillian thank you for all you do
thank you guys for all you do you guys
are such a help
i'm lost again already i don't know what
i'm doing
help walk through help help
help help help
help help help me
restore the great knowledge help
help help you better do something if we
raise 50 000
[ __ ] said emerald chicken
why why no
no riku watch out for the crazed butt
stabber thanks for being you mark thank
you for being you
thank you for all these donations this
is incredible do i do
okay can i drill into you okay
look i don't understand anything i don't
know what's happening
i don't know why nice tucus i don't know
i i i don't know i don't know
i don't know thank you facade
somebody look into the walk-through help
me
help me help help don
thank you help help i'm lost and scared
i'm scared and lost somebody please
help lb help
help help
get the clay tablet on the stairs
what great tablet on the stairs there's
no great tablet on the stairs
there's no gray tablet on the stairs
there's no there's nothing you lie you
lied to me
there's no great tablet on the stairs
under the stairs maybe
under the stairs on the stairs around
the stairs this
no not that this
ah yes this makes so much sense
yeah i'd get this let me just chuck this
priceless piece of
knowledge yes this definitely makes
sense yeah when i read that clue
i would definitely be the one that would
be like oh yeah yeah this
this obscure hunk of rock that i
definitely would have noticed
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no yeah i get
that oh boy the lights are blaring okay
yeah that's that's good
yeah okay can you just magically glue to
wherever
there we go okay put this here okay yeah
that's good
all right well there's one more missing
i don't know where it is
are you in here oh here you are oh
good okay sierra
just wanted to say thank you for your
videos have helped me with the idea
with while i deal with ptsd ps a lot of
marines
love you and love how much you help the
community well thank you
oh there we go
got it wow gimme gimme gimme gimme
i got it uh oh well that doesn't look
good
wait wait wait what the [ __ ] is that
what is that wait a minute whoa hey
whoa
oh thank you
thank you dominique oh so i'm cooper
wait i'm cooper oh
ah interesting
okay
what happens is
you said i was cooper oh [ __ ] um
hey whoa hey uh sheila my daughter
stephanie loves you thank you um
wait hang on i can't lift it up uh
uh uh oh uh no
i got that i got that i got the library
door stuck why wouldn't this get stuck
wait hang on okay i don't have a lantern
anymore um
um
oh boy um oh wait a minute hang on
okay if i stack this here and stack this
here okay here we go here we go here we
go
okay all right that's good that's good
oh yeah that's good okay stack this
here okay oh yeah this is gonna work
this is what i call a genius plan
unstoppable unflappable okay i've got it
and easy peasy oh yeah okay all right
and done easy peasy
well give me a hard one that my big
brain can't solve ah [ __ ]
i'm gonna be squooshed oh god i didn't
solve please don't game over me
i want to live i want to live only oh no
oh my impregnable defense um
ah [ __ ] um
lever is what powers the mechanisms
[Music]
gifted box quickly press oh
oh i oh nicole
hey i send love
uh i can't read it right now hang on
[ __ ]
[ __ ] all right
kobe oh god uh
kobe hey
i did it ugh
hey i send love nicole still on please
give chica extra pets for me i don't
know if my other donation went through
so here
you go boo well thank you so much for
that and thank you minty truffle
it's your birthday happy birthday
oh [ __ ]
okay oh wait i'm back here
what no way
no way okay
all right now i'm getting it now i'm
getting a little bit
i'm getting a little bit of it yeah for
those of you who don't know how to
donate the donation is
right down below in chat it looks like
two hands going like this
it's called super chat it's youtube's
donation system
and it allows you to give a message and
give a hundred percent of your donation
to cfri
thank you timid tabby longtime fan
wishing you continued success and more
hilarious inspiration content
game on mark well thank you so much for
that
scp-105 thank you so much you gave last
night i appreciate that
big preach big priest why don't i have
my preached emoji over here
i have no idea
can i go through here can i get out
oh i guess i can i don't know if i'm
supposed to
it ain't working in the uk unfortunately
yeah it doesn't work
outside of the us at this moment
hopefully they will because i don't know
if people have been using it extensively
it's relatively new but
hopefully people will start using it
again and that will be good
that looks yeah it looks weakened that's
probably fine
i don't know if i'm supposed to go this
way though
yeah i guess i guess i they wouldn't be
stupid enough just to put the orb right
back where it was before right
they wouldn't be that stupid they might
be stupid
but they might not be that stupid
yeah the game could be good if it wasn't
just a little bit
cumbersome i would say that the game is
a little cumbersome
so
oh hey amber jones me and my boyfriend
love watching you thank you for all you
do keep it up okay
um what was that all about
ah joshua draper 500
big donation for big brains working on
big stuff everybody give it up for josh
joshua draper 500
to cfri everybody give it up for josh
everybody give it up for josh oh hell
yeah thank you so much
any member in chat give the heart the
markiplier heart
just start spamming that if you see a
big donation that's worthy of that
to spam the big heart icon
thank you so much for that okay i've
already given you the sanguinary
thank you so much for that
biggest preach huge pre-shawl around
thank you tsukimori okay do i need to do
anything besides just go forward
i don't think so thank you so much
oh you become a member you hit the join
button down below or there's a link in
the description that says support the
channel
oh this is where i dropped it okay yoink
you
stupid pieces of garbage you so stupid
what what
oh oh oh oh
what is that what do i do stay away from
the deadly red lumps
okay yeah i'll stay away from the deadly
red lumps
oh thank you dawn wilson and thank you
endalyn hayner
thank you so much
what the [ __ ] is up with only hearts
it's for the donations like it's just
giving goodwill
no
it's just spreading some love
[Applause]
nope nope no no
run for your life i didn't know thank
you correa
ever thought about doing military bases
or working with you so
i i don't have a show to bring besides
the one that's gonna do
okay i guess i'll run out
okay i'm running for my life get out of
the way box
you're not tiny box tims are you what do
you matter
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh do
you matter you matter you matter god
damn it
you mattered little box oh you're not
tiny but you're little thank you
savannah
all right take two i got this
okay i'm gonna take nothing i'll take
nothing with me
here we go here we go jump jump jump oh
yeah pro level
jumps going on there okay here we go
yum yum yum oh my god i'm so good
thank you isabella okay okay okay okay
uh
yum yup move move move push push push
push him away
get the [ __ ] up away jump jump jump jump
jump
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
sorry
okay
thank you ravin thank you
wolfenda thank you wubb cake thank you
zoe mcgrath wimpy marshmallow
coria endalin dawn
wilson thank you all
for now i thought i was safe i had the
shard but it wasn't over just yet
evidence found in bethesda's castle
suggested to head down to the south town
of sanderholm
in order to acquire the second piece of
the orb even though my body was aching
in pain i couldn't just stop and give up
this was a battle and i was the one
destined to win it
oh [ __ ] you mark you scared my arms into
karate chop mode
oh my god are we done is that the end of
it is that
i know you said it wasn't over just yet
but is that the end
thank you raven is that all
cedar home 20 kilometers why am i
walking
why am i walking oh there i go never
mind i'm not walking anymore i am dying
okay
oh thank you scooter mcgee this is what
more of us need to do help
others thank you mark for all you do i
mean that really is all it is just
helping others
that's all there ever is oh chapter two
[ __ ] that was only chapter one it took
me
four three three hours
three hours to get one two three how
long have i been streaming i have no
three if that's it three hours i feel
like i've been streaming for all day
we've been streaming for three hours and
that's it
holy [ __ ] victoria super chat for good
isn't working on ios mobile devices oh
that's a shame
yeah there's still some bugs to work out
with it but it's it's a start
anyway so uh i think this is as good a
place to end it as any
i want to thank you guys so much uh
number one
like i really honestly truly want to
thank you guys this
was just a test all of this has been a
test i've been doing a lot of tests
lately just to see
if i can like amp up how i do streams
how i do like interactions how i do
things like this
and i'm finding a balance i'm
fine-tuning it and i'm getting there
it's not perfect i know it's not perfect
but it's getting there
i want to do like a
once a week uh-oh incoming i want to do
like a once a week regular live stream
that's just for fun
fun for stuff that it doesn't exist in
any way shape or form
beyond the live stream it's a weekly
thing where we just hang out
and it's not meant for recording videos
it's not meant for anything else
demented love who's buying 500
who is behind me i don't care kill me
thank you what the hell
oh my god heart's all in chat for that
thank you so much demented love demented
love has given stuff already oh my god
the lights are going again
but i i just wanted to say thank you
guys so much for
uh contributing to this i want to do
like more
i know i always say i want to do more
and i really would like to do more and i
i do want to do more but
when it comes down to uh like what i
want to do for this
fluffy cats thank you so much you the
best mark i want to do stuff that is
meant
just for live stream because there's a
different mood to come out of life
500 victoria vanderbock my favorite way
to donate is always during a markiplier
stream seriously though i've been
watching your videos for a few years now
love seeing uh how the uh
how your content evolves keep it up well
thank you god
good god thank you so much oh my god 150
from corrupted rhapsody hey mark my name
is celeste i want to thank you so much
for what you do in all honesty if it
wasn't for you and your videos
i wouldn't be here today this is the
first time i've had money to do
something like this and i'm excited to
thank you for being you
thank you my god oh my god
elizabeth orrell i cried when i saw the
cause you were doing for this i have
it and think you are amazing for doing
this oh my god
like snowball the fluffball you are so
amazing and keep doing what you do
just my god let me speak but thank you
yeah i mean like because there's there's
a certain element
of interaction that comes out of live
and i know that not everyone can
can be there for live streams it is very
time dependent and that doesn't mean i
would do any
less in terms of video production but i
i want to do something because
once a week because it feels like it's
important
it it really does because the way the
world is moving it will it moves more
towards
like live interact oh [ __ ] live
interaction
stuff like that things happening on that
and
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
500 on the gales is a great cause and
you made us all proud love you i'm proud
of you what are you proud about what did
i do i just complained the whole time
that's all i did i just complained and
just like
like i feel like fifty dollars from
youngest baby girl thank you so much and
it's like
it's like these these moments that you
get when it's live that don't exist
anywhere else it's not meant for
like because i've gotten good at
recording
on a live stream thank you joseph symbol
now is a good time to donate 50. yeah it
is
uh i've gotten good at recording on live
streams that are meant
for videos later like i've gotten good
at that yeah hearts
all through chat all hearts all chat all
day um
it's it's just so incredible to see but
there's also something to be said about
having live stream that is meant for
livestream so i don't know what day that
would be i don't know how that's going
to be
um i don't even know how it's going to
exist like but i know i want it
and that's what really matters like i've
got to thank you kyle withers so much
for the 50
and thank you everybody that hasn't just
been donating 50 or 500 or whatever
thank you everybody that's been donating
any amount of money any amount of money
to this charity
that you guys are just giving willingly
to an
incredible like cause is just so
important and it's really good to see
it's it's good to see like you guys
rally around something so simple and yet
so profound
and so like i said i want to do one a
week i don't know how i don't know why
i don't know where i don't know when but
it's something that i know needs to
happen
live the comic thank you i love you mark
you're the reason i'm here today and
this
cause personally affects me thank you so
much well thank you
thank you ian aaron a fifty dollars by
mark had a great time during the live
stream
and uh i'll still fine tune things thank
you so much i'll still fine-tune things
as things go on
i'll keep experimenting i'll keep like
reserving certain things for certain
reactions certain
like thresholds for certain things but i
know that you know
these things are important and not every
stream will be a charity stream but
uh general spyro how is your brother
doing much love oh he's doing great we
had a great time in korea
and uh just thank you guys so much thank
you for being here
um i'm gonna head out hopefully
hopefully i read the last of the
the donations before i go uh but just
thank you guys so much for being here
and just you know you guys are awesome
so
with that thank you again i will let you
guys know in advance
what's coming later on you guys take
care of yourselves have a wonderful day
last one atharin what you've done is
bring us together i may not be able to
give as much to some of the others but
the cause like this is worth
all that i can afford well thank you
honestly truly thank you for that
hope you guys like hope you guys got
something out of this hope you guys felt
a little bit of motivation from this and
i hope you guys got some inspiration out
of this because
that is another thing that comes out of
it like just other people seeing that
this can be done
and people can rally around a cause
at any moment at any time for something
that they truly believe in
that's powerful so you guys even by just
being here
even if you weren't able to contribute
because of whatever financial situation
you're in
and i totally understand that you don't
need to give anything but those who do
give and those who don't give
thank you thank you for being a part of
this community and thank you for being a
part of something bigger than yourself
and thank you for being willing to
extend farther beyond anything
and reach out to others and help those
around you so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always i
will see you
in the next video bye bye bye guys
bye goodbye bye bye
oh and uh cfri has already probably
gotten the money
the money goes directly to them so thank
you bye